hey baby this is your exclusive
behind-the-scenes look of our video for
make it sweet
we're just gonna jump right into it the
song is called make it sweet new song
new video what is going through your
guys's mind right now
I mean we're mostly just hoping the fog
burns off somewhere out there I think is
the ocean
you promised I'm trying to make magic
Hat's you did promise by the time this
interview was over that the fog would be
gone so then we can proceed with our
videos it's true hard to tell in the
actual music video but the guys were
plagued by some heavy fog on shoot day
in Malibu this is what they mean when
you say you have your head in the clouds
only et was on set with all Dominion
it's just a fun like carefree feeling
and just a good vibe so it's just trying
to capture that emotion that that way of
life sort of it's just like having fun
yeah people have fun California seems to
make its way in our music a lot in this
song has that sort of California West
Coast 5 to it too so this is perfect
[Music]
there's five of you guys when you sit
down and you talk about what you want
out of a music video any disagreements
are you guys always on the same page
yeah we never agree on anything
video shoot yeah it's all the other days
are fine yeah I try to just like look
this isn't my thing
started like it's not none of it is our
thing so it's hard to be like you know
we're like we know someone get a
director to help us I don't stand here
yeah
[Laughter]
take off the see Jason let that surf
Santa
[Music]
what are three things that make your
guys lives just a little bit sweeter
coffee music tequila and coffee yeah
the new single is off the band's
upcoming third album why was this the
perfect song to be that first date new
single from it when we got this song
done and played and which it just has a
thing to it it feels like it it could
take us somewhere even bigger
[Music]
how do you feel like you guys have
evolves and that last record that in a
lot of ways I think a lot of time spent
together so just are playing and our
writing and the crowds all of it plays
into your growth so I mean we've
definitely we know each other's ends and
outs for sure so that happens with our
writing a mix are writing tighter it
makes our playing tighter so hopefully
we can play our instruments a little bit
better how far off are we from hearing
that complete record are you guys still
songwriting for it are you done no yeah
you never know if you've done
we definitely have Apollo songs and
we're going in to record in a couple
weeks the guys have all written for
other artists too trevor rosenthal
sangria for blake shelton but it was
actually meant for another country star
[Music]
sangria angry kenny actually recorded it
and then didn't make the album of course
i was bummed I'm like man I'm sad a
Kenny Chesney cut but then you know
everything works itself out Blake
Shelton
yeah so sometimes it takes a couple
tries but the new tune is all old women
[Music]
that's one of those songs that I think
changes your bottle you put it on you
just feel the air lift a little bit old
dominion that is a wrap
[Applause]
[Music]